>> Announcer: This is CNN
breaking news.
>>> Let's get straight to the
Sources now telling CNN that
Russian naval craft have arrived
at the site of the U.S. Drone
downing in the black sea.
CNN's orrin leiberman is working
his sources for us over at the
Pentagon.
Orin, U.S. Officials believe the
wreckage would be extremely
difficult to retrieve, but the
Russians appear to be trying.
What are you hearing from your
sources.
>> Reporter: Two U.S. Officials
tell us the Russian Navy,
essentially Russian assets in
the black sea were able to reach
the crash site of the m-q9
drone.
The Russian Navy has ships based
in crimea so it wouldn't have
been that difficult for them to
get their ships to crash site.
Of course the crucial question
is this is what's unclear is how
much if anything the Russians
were able to uncover from the
m-q9 drone.
Earlier today with press
secretary Lloyd Austin and mark
Milly it was Milly who said
there probably isn't all that
much wreckage to recover.
It was about 4,000 to 5,000 feet
deep of water there.
But the Russians according to
the U.S. Officials were able to
get to that site.
Earlier today a senior Russian
official promised that the
Russians would try to recover
what they could from that drone
and learn what's possible.
Milly had said the U.S. Had
taken steps to mitigate the
collection of any sensitive
data.
We reported earlier today that
before that drone, the U.S.
Drone that has crashed into the
black sea, its operators were
able to wipe the sensitive data,
the sensitive software
information used in intelligence
collection from the drone.
Meaning that though there may be
some wreckage there, the U.S.
Believes there isn't sensitive
top secret data just sitting
there on top of the black sea.
Meanwhile the Pentagon promising
it'll keep operating over
international waters and giving
the sense of how they view the
Russian actions here.
>> I'll just reiterate that the
United States will fly and
operate wherever international
law allows.
Now, we take any potential for
escalation very seriously, and
that's why I believe it's
important to keep the lines of
communication open.
>> So was it intentional or not?
Don't know yet.
We know that the intercept was
intentional.
We know the aggressive behavior
was intentional.
We also know it was very
unprofessional and very unsafe.
The actual contact of the fixed
wing Russian fighter with our
uav, the physical contact of
those two, not sure yet.
That remain Tuesday be seen, but
I can't -- I can tell you with
certainty, though, we have
absolute evidence of the contact
and the intercepts, et cetera.
And it's very aggressive.
You've heard about the dumping
of the fuel and everything else.
We have video evidence of all
that.
We know where it landed in the
black sea.
Probably about 4, 5,000 feet of
water.
Recovery efforts are very
difficult at that depth by
anyone.
It probably broke up and
probably not a lot to recover,
frankly.
As far as the loss of anything
sensitive intelligence, et
cetera, as normal we would
take -- and we did take
mitigating measures.
So we are quite confident that
whatever was of value is no
longer of value.
>> In the day and a half or so
since this happened there's been
a number of communications both
in the diplomatic channel and
now in the military channel
here.
And what it seems there's
agreement upon there's no desire
from the U.S. Or Russia for
escalation around this specific
incident.
However, the cause of the
incident that's where we have
entire disagreements.
The U.S. Making their case clear
there from both Milly and Austin
that it was the Russian fighter
jets who were acting in a
reckless fashion there.
Meanwhile, in a call between
Austin and his counterpart, the
Russian defense minister, the
minister essentially tried to
lecture Austin about the U.S.
Actions here saying the U.S.
Flew the drone in a provocative
fashion, flying around crimea is
itself provocative and Russia
had essentially declared there
was some sort of airspace around
its, quote, special military
operation the U.S. Should have
avoided.
Wolf, there's still certainly
disagreement on the cause of
this, but at least it seems
there's no desire to escalate
from this point.
>> We shall see.
Orenleiberman at the Pentagon,
thank you very much.
Joining us now top white house
national security official John
Kirby.
John, thanks for joining us.
I want to begin with our new
reporting that the Russians have
now reached the site of the
drone crash.
Is there any cause for concern
it Russia eventually recovers
this debris from the drone?
>> Well, I certainly can't
confirm the reports they're on
the site.
I'm aware of their comments of
trying to get there and trying
to recover.
But the short answer to your
question is no.
As general Milly made clear, we
made it impossible for them to
be able to glean anything of
intelligence value off the
remnants of that drone, whatever
remnants there might be on the
surface of the water.
>> Because as you just point out
other U.S. Officials have said
they've managed to actually
erase sensitive software on the
drone remotely before it
actually crashed into the black
sea.
Does this debris have any value
for Russia, though, even if just
for propaganda?
>> It's really going to be
difficult to say, wolf.
I would tend towards no.
Whatever is left of that that's
floating will probably be flight
control surfaces, that kind of
thing, probably nothing of real
intrinsic value to them in terms
of re-engineering or anything
like that.
We're not overly concerned about
whatever they might get their
hands on.
That said and secretary Austin
said this today, it's our
property, and they have no
business recovering anything.
>> As you know the U.S. Does not
currently have any ships the
black sea.
Is the Biden administration
considering taking any steps to
keep this downed drone out of
Russia's hands?
>> I think the Pentagon is still
taking a look at whatever
recovery options might be
available to them.
I think you can imagine that
they're fairly limited given we
don't have a naval presence in
the black.
I don't want to get ahead of the
defense department and what they
might be thinking.
>> There are other navies that
we partner with and have
terrific relationships with in
the black sea and I would refer
to the defense department I
don't know plans to use ally
naval assets to attempt
recovery.
I want to stress, wolf.
Again, it's our property and we
certainly don't want the
Russians getting it, but we're
not overly concerned about
anything they might glean off of
it.
Russia is publicly accusing the
United States of what it calls
violations of what it calls its
flight restriction zone in that
black sea area.
Should we expect to see Russia
continue to escalate as it tries
to establish new rules in the
skies?
>> We don't want to see
escalation here and there's no
need for that.
This m-q9 was flying in
international airspace and we're
going to continue to fly and
operate where international law
permits us to.
That's what we did in this case.
That's what we'll continue to
do.
We have real national security
interests and all that effort is
going to continue.
>> Secretary Austin and general
Milly both spoke with their
Russian counter parts today and
that was significant.
Has the Biden administration
received any assurances at all
from Russia it'll stop engaging
in these kind of aggressive acts
against the United States like
the downing of this drone, for
example?
>> We made it very clear.
I know the defense department
did in their calls, and we made
it clear this is unacceptable
and don't want to see any repeat
occurrences of this.
We have laid bare our concerns